having a nice year and i mean as a
starter he has been outstanding he is
four and one as a starter
tries to punch maybe take it take and
jose ramirez has that for out number one
kyle schwarber 264 with 26 home runs
and is a high fly deep center did he get
one backing up straw leaping he can't
get it it's out of here
wow shorebro a number 27 on the red sox
strike early
and the home runs come in bunches i've
mentioned that before and there it is
again
jd martinez returning the lineup today
and that's up the middle for a base hit
jd martinez on quickly with a single
that snaps an old for 20. here's xander
bogart's in
and he's going to turn on this and wrap
it down the line that's an extra base
hit
martinez into third jd coming around and
trying to score him here's the throw
it's cut back into thirds xander bogarts
will be tagged out red sox pick up
another run and now lead it two to
nothing
and a ground ball right back to
quantrill
so the red sox get too quickly
nate has mentioned it's throwing the
ball very well at progressive field 3-0
here with a 292 era and four career
outings
little flare coming on is schwarber to
make the catch one gun
when chasing 96 up and out of the zone
and of all the fans in his first k in
the book today
a high fly
center field there's duran
and wally gets him in order to get this
one underway
foreign leading off the bottom of the
second indians down two nothing
hit pretty well deep left center field
it is
going to souvenir city
home run number 24 for the franimal
it's the indians on the board here in
inning number two here's bradley zimmer
the indians right fielder and a line
drive right center field that's in the
alley that'll get down it'll go to the
wall
zimmer on his way to second lookout
when he jumped on the brakes and i would
love it
i thought for sure he was going to third
now bobby bradley back with a big league
ball club
that's fisted and he grips with drops
center field zimmer's coming around with
a tight run throw way off line he scores
easily it's a 2-2 game
i jammed him but he fought it off gets
it into play zimmer went back the right
thing to do but with his speed hudson's
just gonna wave him right around and he
scores he could have scored standing up
edges will swing and pop it up
bogey and a shallow left
in there for strike three
yeah ximena's trying to go the other way
deep down the left field line it's a
fair ball
oh what a perfect ricochet for schwarber
and that's going to keep bradley from
being able to score
[Applause]
a double down the line by ximenez
swing and a miss he did he struck him
out
and contains it a bit just two runs in
two two game
got him looking
back door slider he's done that a couple
of times both of his strikeouts once to
uh verdugo and now to arrows
funny how the human mind does not let us
escape our recent failures what just
happened there let's see and
point out
waved at striking out cointreau gets
duran
boy what a great pitch change up you can
see he was out front weak ground ball
one two three cal quantro making the
adjustments since that first inning is
set down seventh straight
got him to chase inside the zone he
struck him out for the second time
setting up inside how about that swing
wow corkscrewed
i mean watch i've never seen a hitter do
the things that jose does in there that
ball would almost hit him in the back
knee
he struck him out two down
there it is
he struck him out he strikes out the
side here in the third i'll tell you
these two are locked in a very good
pitchers duel right now
and there's a ball hammered up the alley
off the wall go front meal go
he's on his way to second base with a
one-out double
so that will do it for native aldi he
gets the hook here in the sixth inning
with one down
and he does lay off that time
swung on and missed he strikes him out
went right at him 95 miles an hour and
popped him up there's xander
he's got it
up the middle a sliding stab by himman
as throws not gonna get him no chance
for dugo with a base hit
ready to go there he goes
and it's up high walked him
so that's ball four
and he drops it down toward third
that'll get it done
throw the first in time to get him for
dugo into third vazquez into second
oh nice popped him up nice
it away two down
fly ball left field jim johnson going
back
and
makes the catch to end the inning
and the 3-2
broken bat he'll have to hurry oh no no
he will
that ball
stopped in the grass
at a boy about that a four pitch yeah
now you're set up
he bunts he pops it up everybody gets
back and a big big first out
comebacker off the glove he looked at
second gothie out there
so they move up to second and third but
two down he had a shot at two i think
they're just gonna walk them they do
smart thing to do
you have the bases loaded and you got
the ready to face reyes
three two coming
he got him he struck him out
and leaves the bases loaded so schwarber
to lead it off a home run a ground out
and a strikeout in his 27th home run in
the first inning he'll tag this one
all the way to the warning track as
zimmer scoops and fires that'll be a
long single
lion drive and a base hitting the right
schwarber rounding he's into third
and a red sox on the attack first and
third with two down
swing at a miss hayes struck him out
foul tip hung on by hedges
didn't work again
he had a little quick pitch on the 3-2
and there's the patience once again
and in betweener and they'll only get
the out at first ah that's a good job by
zimmer
make that big turn looking for third
base
reached out
davis will go take it over to the ball
i love seeing zimmer put the after
burners on when he was running to first
base
all right gets a second out
swing at a high pop-up
and once again gary richards comes out
of the bullpen and he is golden in the
eighth inning we go to the night duran
the base runner
so the fastest man on the diamond will
be at second base here in the 10th
goes the other way in a base hit into
left center
charging onto mercado and they're going
to hold the runner
duran will be held at third base
a base hit for schwarberg's third knock
today jd martinez a base hit in the
first base hit in the sixth red sox
would take it again right here
there's a shot
that's driven to right zimmer's back
he's turning it's gone he hit it out of
here
jd martinez with a three-run blast
the red sox finally back on the
scoreboard jd comes to life today
and a red sox lead it five to two
[Applause]
oh no
nice play by bobby bradley
another bullet in the right field for a
base hit
two hits for raffy today he has himself
a single
double turn
turn it four six
three they get it in time to end the
inning
and now the three two
high ball four so you've got your chance
now
oh
baby how are we doing well he saved
himself five pitches
he struck him out
martin comes back strong and fans
bradley big first out
got him 95 elevated he blew him away
two down so the indians are down to
their last out
it will be up to oscar mercado
ground ball right side that's going to
get through
they'll score two
oh no they stopped grandma reyes and
throw goes back to second was whisker
close you got to be careful you're
losing you can't take any chances well
they get one in
ground ball and a play here for our ooze
and that will do it the red sox pull it
out
they win again and have beaten the
indians 5-3 to take the series
high drama once again at the end
[Applause]